[Musique]
portrait croisé de Jane Birkin et Serge
Gainsbourg vedette du film cannabis de
Pierre Coralie
cartina
un petit peu de un côté simple
[Musique]
à ce que j'aime sèche ça c'est et qui
n'a pas une raison c'est juste vu et vu
le comme ça alors sans expiration mais
ça vient un petit à petit dans le film
je le vois
on voit pas qu'il y a grand chose il n'y
a pas une dans une dans le quart tout de
suite mais c'est petit à petit on veut
pas le laisser c'est comme moi
maintenant c'est une imaginable d'être
pas avec lui et il a les soucis et des
complexes et des difficultés comme dans
le film ils ont
désespéré il est foutu
moi je suis assez usagé aussi
ma première fois je l'ai vu
anglais je pense que si c'était que ça
il y a plein de filles plus jeunes et il
y a plein de filles plus anglais que moi
qui suis
d'origine russe
seulement une éducation et française
et alors la Russie et l'Angleterre ça
fait un cocktail
c'était pas son visage je vais m'en
sortir
j'ai trouvé
il était mais ça c'était sa façon
c'était sa façon de
il n'avait pas de carte SIM ou de
gentillesse mais j'ai compris après ce
que j'ai pris pour agressivité c'était
une grande timidité ce qu'on appelle un
visage un grand
qu'il devrait une reconnaissance
je m'habitue parfois je
suis en dépression alors je trouve
ignoble parfaitement
ignoble d'autres fois pas mal pas mal
c'est un visage qu'on peut pas oublier
maintenant que j'ai vu je peux pas
oublier mais ça me va très bien que tout
le monde pense qu'il est un fruit et
tout ça quand j'étais petite j'avais une
perquet qui manque tout le monde sauf
moi il m'adorait parce que j'ai
osé lui chatouiller dessus les ailes
tout le monde dit comment tu peux aimer
cette affaire j'ai pensé d'y aller très
gentille mais je veux pas que les autres
ça c'était une secrète
c'est pas très intéressant
la gueule de Michel Simon
crépuscule à 90 ans encore j'aimais
toujours des comptes j'ai pas un type
devant mon miroir je me noie dans mon
miroir parce que je sais pas
ce sont des autres troubles dangereux
[Musique]
américains pour certains c'est le reflet
de
ciel pour moi
ce qu'il veut lui qui est celle que j'ai
pris au premier coup moi aussi j'ai
pensé qu'il était fini qui était
où on peut dire sa vie et tout ça
marrant et puis ça paraît étonnant
c'est vrai quand j'étais petit je
faisais rire mais petite sœur en larmes
ça peut paraître un corps
[Musique]
il allait invinci en d'un enfant il a
tous les jeux avec ma fille que j'aurais
jamais pensé à faire
comme une fille de la lumière peut voir
un homme de Londres
assez vice
il y en a un qui souffre et l'autre qui
s'ennuie
et je suis pas tellement
pour le moment
il souffle aussi de temps en temps
et parfois tu n'es même on a les mêmes
rapports on veut faire les mêmes choses
et
il est très difficile de vivre avec mais
qui veut le faciliter ça c'est un ennui
je peux faire ça
tout le temps c'est mieux parce que
juste ça
ils sont voué à l'échec
il faut vivre dangereusement les
instants de chaque jour
et s'installer dans
la sécurité
de prévoir
ses sentiments
soit d'une grande pièce
[Musique]